and the winner of this year's Mojave Max
emergence contest is a fifth grader from
Rundle Elementary on the Valley's East
Side say hello to edin Corden we visited
his classroom he guessed that the desert
tortoise would crawl out of his Borough
at the Springs Preserve at 3 14 p.m on
April 24th his actual time of emergence
3 40. so is really close teacher Mr Monk
and Eden each getting laptop computers
at their field trip to the Springs
Preserve next week that's where the
entire class will meet Max in person
have a pizza party you know the desert
tortoise here is a much better predictor
of spring-like weather for the desert
Southwest and that groundhog
Punxsutawney Phil who lives in
Pennsylvania proud to be part of the
Mojave Max team for more than 20 years
Sherry